here are the rules of the game this is
Sam hi from Wendover Productions half as
interesting and especially jet lag the
game and today we're going to get taken
to about five or ten minutes distance
apart in central London the first to
take a photo of the other one and send
in the group chat wins on the phone are
Ben and Adam also from jet lag the game
they're going to be our handlers they're
going to tell us where to go and while
we can we can hide we can duck and dive
a bit we can't go in a direction to find
someone or avoid someone without their
say-so
right you ready yeah let's do it
all right we're going three two one
let's go which way do I go all right uh
you're gonna want to start by going
north but I also don't want us to just
have you go straight towards him right
we're gonna need to be strategic but I
would start off okay heading north um on
I believe it's called paring done street
is that a street that is there
no I see New Bridge Street and I see
Queen Victoria Street okay that's
fascinating
um
and uh just head north
um away from the river I really think we
have to draw Tom to a big open space
because that's going to be the the
easiest area to NAB him in the photo
while we can hide and especially
thinking about ones that he can't really
sneak around yes okay so you're near
you're near kind of two Fields you're
near Grays in gardens
uh which is which is right north of you
okay and you're also near Lincoln uh
Lincoln's in fields which is right to
the west of you okay so grazin is bigger
so we should go to that maybe so Tom my
thought on the best way to do this is
that these tractors show location like
in a you know an XY sense but they don't
show hype so if there's any way that you
can get to an elevation differential I
think that that would be enough to throw
them off
and potentially get us a pick elevation
differential uh I mean I can do that
there's a set of stairs directly to the
right of me that go up somewhere but I
feel like they'll have The High Ground
because they're going to come in that
way well you'll want to get closer okay
I'll bear that in mind which way do you
want me to go keep going north
um there there are good ways North yeah
I think we've got to take advantage of
the fact that I'm I think I'm gonna be
faster moving in Tom both because he has
a backpack gone and I don't and because
like I'm taller I have longer legs and
stuff so let's use speed as an advantage
oh Tom Tom is moving quite quickly he's
moving quite quickly towards you you may
be wrong Tom might be faster than you
thought he's very powerful he's a very
powerful Foe and you should be very
scared is he just trying to wear me out
so I have to come to him because I'm
pretty sure I'd say I'd say it's very
hard to tell what he is trying to do
um so it looks like you're North you
should be passing Ludgate Hill right yep
yep I'm just gonna wait until I've got
the green lights crossed this is good
enough you can also take a left you know
what why not take a left on a Feather
Lane because North is so predictable
yeah take a left okay okay you should be
near
Grays in gardens now can you see them
they should be to your left there's a
big there's a wall
I don't again I don't know if this is
like a a place that you're allowed to go
to
let's learn about Gray's in Garden yeah
let's learn about grazing with more
expediency you sound too relaxed oh it
looks I'm in the thick of it it's closed
yeah it looks beautiful what it's it
opens at 12 P.M
on Monday 236. on Monday
this GPS is not good at telling me the
name of streets
oh that's gonna work really well for us
yeah it's gonna be really great I think
take a right
okay Noah left
what that's the other direction you got
stuck with the wrong guy take a left I'm
allowed to wait for three minutes
without moving and then I have to move
on so like do I just wait here and hang
around and wait for them to approach I
would yeah why don't we give them a
minute and why don't we also have a
quick chat about potential plans that
they might have in ways that we can can
subvert them so I think one thing we're
going to want to avoid is we never want
a situation where we're in the middle of
a street and they're coming around the
corner onto that street because I think
that that's gonna agree
agreed we want we want the corners I'm
going to bring you down towards
Lincoln's in field there's like a gazebo
in the center and they're like paths
around it and there's like a building or
so it kind of look it looks like a
public park it's like a public park yeah
I think that I think that this might be
a good space to to catch them Tom is
also sort of heading that direction he's
heading towards Lincoln's in fields
um but he's he's still south of it I
wonder if he if he's also gone for the
defensive strategy I want to move
towards Sam as quickly as possible so
they start to panic and make bad
decisions
I think that that is a great plan so all
right which which way which one uh let's
go uh
hmm let's see here I can go north up
shoe lane or west or east on Fleet
Street
why don't we go north
and one thing we need to think about is
if we do end up trying to get him in the
park
like where should we visit where should
we be positioned in the park to draw him
across because he's of course going to
be
conscious of the risk you know he's
going to know I'm there he's going to be
conscious of the risk of going across an
open area so
I'm running do I need to run no
absolutely not there are lots of there
appear to be lots of trees okay so you
think hiding within in in the park is
the best strategy I think hiding in the
park will probably work pretty well if I
go north along Saint Andrew Street that
meets what I think is high hoping yes
which is the street that they are headed
towards now it appears right if I go
north east from here along shoe Lane
okay that takes me to the bottom of that
takes me underneath High Hopes now I
don't know if there are stairs up there
there might be so in theory I could pop
up and see them there or you know I
don't know when that's worth laying a
trap I'm only allowed to stay in one
place for a few minutes all right let's
put some pressure on let's move towards
them I love We're not gonna go to where
they are and try to get the picture yet
but if they are forced to move after
this three minutes then I think it will
be in a good position where then they
might have to start heading towards us
because they're going to use up their oh
wait are they in the mood now no they're
moving now okay okay they're moving
which one I think go up shoe Lane go
northeast up shoe Lane try to get under
high hold roughly how far away is Tom
like in distance
um like a quarter mile point a mile okay
so that's a good margin
this is assuming there are stairs to get
me between here on shoe Lane and up to
high hoping let's see if there are
[Music]
no there aren't oh there's no connection
between the two down
okay okay things are starting to get to
get interesting I think you guys are
about to be basically on the same street
I am wide open find me a place to run to
okay um go
just go can you keep going up shoe Lane
can you cross eye Holborn
I'm crossing under high Holden now okay
great there is uh there's an arch where
I can dive no there's a security guard I
can't go in there
um you might have to take a left until
you get to Holborn place
Holborn place okay let's jaywalk
there's a door that's set back from the
street
I can hide against this wall and if they
go over that bridge I've got them oh
that seems better they know where I am
so like but and also how long until they
get here maybe it may be as little as
three minutes but it may be longer but
they are headed directly towards us on
High Holborn
I'm gonna go under the bridge okay I'm
gonna go under the bridge and I'm gonna
tell the tracker that I am absolutely on
that street I am absolutely not in no
way am I waiting on a street below for
them
by the way I am wide open if they head
for shoe Lane
then tell me to run because I am so wide
open right now they'll get me
immediately okay okay you guys are on
the same road you're both on High
Holborn okay okay how long until they
turn right
uh take it basically whenever you can
how long until a road to turn right well
you passed Holborn place
oh so that's what I'm supposed to take
yeah oh we gotta go back there though I
thought you were kind of just like
vibing out you know you're telling me
Ben you got to tell me okay turn back
around go downhole I'm turning back
around two minutes I'm gonna have to
move there's a oh you're moving away
they're moving away from us it looks
like they're moving away from High
Holborn back down they're headed west
now
okay what are they doing they've
chickened out I think
I keep promoting nordvpn here in part
because I keep finding new uses for them
sure I can tell websites and apps on my
computer and phone or in some other
country I've talked about that before
but the other week I was using Wi-Fi on
a plane and they had blocked YouTube
entirely okay they want to stop people
using too much data sure except I didn't
want to watch stuff I just wanted to
check that a new video had launch
properly so I clicked a button and
nordvpn created a secure tunnel from my
laptop through to their servers and I
could get my work done you may have
other things that you want to access
past filters or as if you're in one of
about 60 other countries but for me
nordvpn just keeps being helpful for my
job it'll work on Windows Mac Linux IOS
and Android on up to six devices at the
same time there's also a 30-day
money-back guarantee if you want to test
it out first if you go to nordvpn.com
plus you'll find the best deal they're
currently offering
now if I remember right I was trying to
avoid heading into Sam's trap okay I'm
taking this left it's not a road it's
just like a pedestrian passageway so it
might not show up as big
is it like lit it's yeah it's called
like little Turn Style
sure yeah yeah hopefully that I think
that can bring you down to the the park
you know what should we just chase them
I would say chase them I say go go down
hide Holborn and see to see where we can
get I can see I'm on like the corner of
a park yeah that's that is that's the
one the park okay so which direction
should I go to be on the opposite side
of Tom
[Music]
um you are you are on the opposite side
of town right now he's headed towards uh
towards a field I can't really tell if
that field has elevation what's what's
the name of it Lincoln's in fields do
you know that Lincoln's and Fields is a
is a park right so it's very wide open
but it does have a lot of things to hide
behind
if he wants to force a showdown that's
not a bad place to do it it's showing
that there's like uh there's like a
little restaurant in the oh I think I
see that like maybe you could use that
yeah he probably wouldn't do you think
they would know that that's a building
here's why I feel like I'm walking into
a trap I'm concerned that they seem to
have a strategy and it feels like we no
longer do yeah well we had a strategy
which was like get close and panic them
and I guess that worked because they ran
here's the good news they appear to be
camping and we are now which means that
their campaign clock is going to end
before an artist yeah Tom is now heading
south
South okay along the in the park or
along the road he's still a block from
the park so I think he might be trying
to enter the park from the south
huh what do you think we should do then
well it might be worth well I guess
let's just see what he does
should we just go to the other side of
the park then yeah let's let's continue
I think we should Circle it
starting to get into what my father
calls rubber pants time
okay uh the British equipment will be
squeaky bum time well
Simon's pulling some Shenanigans like he
doesn't jet like the game where he's
found some like little loophole that he
thinks is valid in the rules it's like
oh yeah you could only stay in one place
for three minutes I hope I'm going to
different corners of Lincolnton fields
because I I still like our defensive
strategy I still think it's the right
strategy but eventually we're just gonna
have to change gears and maybe go on the
offensive well we could start heading
towards him but that's going to put us
at a distance it's risky yeah this is
clearly a trap
but also we know that right and we know
he's in the middle of fields so is he
going to as soon as we approach he's
going to Sprint for whichever corner of
the field I'm approaching from and try
and get me first
so instead do I just kind of get to the
closest corner and try and get a really
long shot
of him standing in the middle of a field
so I'm gonna just stand in the middle
here for now and then I think maybe
Retreat to one of these kind of big wide
trees that we can hide behind I don't
like that my let's aggressively chase
them down idea that's Lincoln's in feels
all right I can hang on hang on hang on
I'm gonna dive for hiding here hold on
okay how far are they from the perimeter
of the park
about a quarter block
a quarter block okay I need to hide that
but you're I mean you're on the opposite
end of the park so I think you're you're
yeah it can be fairly open
okay oh
have they turned around again
okay the tracker is is a bit off which
is interesting okay now wait okay so
where do they think I am where do they
think I am they they should think that
you're further down the street than you
are so they shouldn't realize you have a
sight line okay
run it now and see if you can get them
before they realize that you're there
okay they may be entering the park now
it appears they may have entered the
park
okay are you are you hidden
they're directly in the middle a little
bit Northwest Northeast Northeast a
little bit Northeast there should be a
large sort of like House of some kind or
uh there is tennis courts and then there
should be a sort of a clubhouse I'm
thinking that yeah they are they are
just your Northeast they're in the
middle to the Northeast you are both in
the park you should be able to see you
might be able to see them at any moment
best foliage everywhere okay okay that's
interesting we're absolutely ready to go
I would hide a clubhouse they should be
directly to your right potentially
they're hiding like right at the corner
of the restaurant
oh I see something red
is it Tom
no oh no
that that's got to be Tom right
that's not clear ah even a red shirt
isn't identifiable I've got the camera
app open I'm zoomed in they're headed
Northeast they appear to be headed
potentially towards the northeast corner
of the way I think they're directly in
line with you they should be directly to
your right as far as I can tell wait all
the way across the field
okay just stay covered stay very covered
I am doing because they are here I'm
doing where are they Ben they're they're
still on the sort of
western side of the restaurant now
they're going alongside the southern
edge of the restaurant
heading towards you to the east if they
if they move west at all let me know but
there is a there's a back route
just sneaking down I'm between the
clubhouse and the tennis courts
there is a little Alleyway a little
Alleyway okay okay I don't think they've
noticed okay hang on can you see them
here anywhere again be really careful be
really careful they are you're headed
you look to be headed Easter yeah I'm
literally going along the tennis club oh
you're heading towards them you're
headed towards them if you're heading
okay they've got to be right there
they've got to be right you should be me
you you should be I mean I would say
you're a third of the length of the park
from Sam
I'm just looking through trees
I assume he's got to be doing the same
can I change trees safely
um I mean you're pretty exposed now
they're they're very close to you okay
let me check and then have not moved
trees
oh okay they're now they're now on the
Eastern side of the restaurant
so you should theoretically be able to
see them
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna Retreat one
tree okay
[Music]
oh I'm sweating
oh
I had to slide out
he is is there an intersection of like
three sort of Paths of of paths like
Crossing perpendicularly in the middle
of this part yes
just to the east of that
he's I can't see him why can't I see him
I mean I'm in a bright red t-shirt I've
got to be visible I'm gonna hide behind
a Hut here
all right we need to develop we all
right let's let's try to figure out a
plan here all right if you see this to
the northeast of the tennis courts
there's a little Hut okay okay
I am parked I'm on the west side of that
Hut okay Ben I have my camera on my
watch
so my so I'm not exposing myself out
oh you can see via my watch
sneaky is his Northeast tobacco sibo
how the hell is he Northeast of the
Gazebo I can see Northeast of the gazebo
he must be I'm gonna hide behind a tree
running
I think I should move
I'm gonna Retreat to another tree okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait I have no idea probably I
don't know if that's him
running I've got a I got him I've got
him I've got him I've got him it's sent
it's sent it's sent I got it I got him
they are the two people hiding just
there you can see the legs to the left
of that tree
got you
you see the legs I see who's things that
potentially could be legs oh Tom got it
first oh no
foreign
the red Blended in much better than I
thought that's it right there oh
incredible work Tom that was all I see
your legs I really hope I really hope
that the camera on the GoPro caught that
I wouldn't have known those were your
legs unless you ran
I saw it I saw three legs there oh and I
went is that them I mean that was
definitely right I got your legs that
was no I checked the tree it was the
tree it was the tree it was 100 Adam how
are you doing I am incredible Tom there
are few things that I love more in the
world than for Sam to have a complicated
plan and then for it to fail completely
and uh and Ben how are you doing I you
know it I thought we had them I thought
we had set the perfect trap uh but your
your damn legs are too long and visible
yeah but we had fun right
we had fun so we win because that's all
that matters Tom whose idea was setting
the Trap Ben whose idea was setting the
Trap I would say that it was uh your
producer who came up with that idea
our producer that way no one can be
blamed
oh we're just blaming it on the producer
oh yeah I'm all for that yeah sure got
it
thanks for playing Sam thanks Tom well
played